this maternity hospital in India's
southern city of Raichu is busier than
usual
the government facility where about 600
babies are born every year is no longer
hampered by an erratic power supply
after installing solar panels deliveries
go smoothly and vaccines and medicines
are stored safely at controlled
temperatures
before installing solar panels we often
worked in darkness raichur has lots of
power problems we had no electricity for
four to five hours a day we were
delivering babies using torches and
lamps the hospital is one of 250 medical
facilities in The District in Karnataka
that runs on solar energy each panel was
installed by a non-profit group for a
once-off fee of about eight thousand
five hundred dollars
the shift to clean energy is not just
cutting emissions it's also cutting
costs when solar is installed I observed
two times it's like it's more of 50
percent reduced
so small businesses are taking their cue
and connecting to the solar grid and so
are thousands of houses
nearly 30 million people are in rural
India labs to the access of electricity
uh so promoting of this such kind of
electric uh clean cooking or even the
oat fire Chula which is not result in a
huge uh government subsidies and
substantial health and environmental
hazards so solar power here offers an
opportunity to bridge this massive
infrastructure Gap
India's population of 1.4 billion is
largely dependent on coal the dirtiest
form of fossil fuel for electricity but
in recent years the government has
shifted towards a more sustainable
future expenditure budget that
government of India had came out of in
2020 324 around 49.7 billion was
allocated for the green interactive
solar rooftop projects and 19.96 billion
for solar based water pumping systems
and 3.61 billion for off-grid solar
power projects the ministry of new and
renewable energy says more than 60 000
megawatts of solar power has been
installed in recent years
adopting clean energy is Central to
meeting sustainability goals and efforts
to combat climate change
but India has a long way to go several
cities including the capital New Delhi
are ranked among the most polluted in
the world